[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم شهداء في اقتحام اعداد
كبيره من قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي معززه
بقوات خاصه مدينه جنين ومخيمها وفي نابلس
قوات الاحتلال تعتقل عددا من الفلسطينيين
والنطق العسكري الاسرائيلي يقول ان
العمليتين في جنين ونابلس تتعلقان بعمليه
حواره
على وقع معارك محتدمه في جبهات القتال
شرقيه اوكرانيا متحدثا باسم القوات
الاوكرانيه يقول للجزيره ان الوضع في
بخموت تحت سيطره رغم ارسال موسكو قوات
فاجنر واكثر وحداتها تدريبا مؤكدا ان قرار
القياده الاوكرانيه هو مواصله القتال
بعد يوم من تاكيد المدير العام للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ان فصلا جديدا بدا
في العلاقه مع طهران بيان امريكي اسرائيلي
يؤكد تعزيز التنسيق لمنع ايران من حيازه
سلاح النووي والعمل على وضع حد لما سماه
النفوذ الايراني في المنطقه
بعد مظاهرات واضراب عام احتجاجا على مشروع
قانون التقاعد شلل في قطاع النقل في مختلف
المدن الفرنسيه وتوقعات بالغاء ثلث
الرحلات الجويه من مطاري باريس
في